so let's see if we can get a big picture
of everything that's happening in this
credit default swap market so I'll speak
in generalities so let's say we have
corporation a corporation a corporation
B corporation C and let's say we have I
don't we have a bunch of people who
write the credit default swaps and I'll
call them insurers because that's
essentially what a credit default swap
is it's insurance on debt if someone
doesn't pay the debt then the insurance
company will pay it for you and in
exchange you're essentially giving some
of the interest on the debt so let's say
we have insurer one insurer one let's
say we have insurer two and some of
these were insurance companies some of
these were banks some of these may have
even been hedge funds so these are the
people who write the credit default
swaps and then there are the people who
would actually buy the credit default
swap so in that in the previous example
I had pension fund one that was my
pension fund and then you could have
another pension fund pension fund - and
let's just see let's redraw some of the
the connections between the
organizations so maybe I let's say
pension fund one were to lend 1 billion
dollars to a a will pay pension fund one
and no 10% but pension fund 1 wants to
make sure that they'll definitely get
the money because they can't lend money
to people with anything less than
stellar credit ratings so they get some
insurance from insurer 1 so what they do
is out of this 10% they pay them some of
the basis points so let's say they pay
them 100 basis points 100 basis points
and in exchange they get I'll call it
insurance on a this is this new notation
that I'm creating they get insurance on
a fair enough and that's and the reason
why this this
I won this in this first insurer was
able to do that is because Moody's has
given them a very high credit rating and
so when they insure something it's
you're essentially the total package
right the loan to this guy plus the
insurance kind of is like you're lending
the money to this guy but you're just
getting more insurance you're getting
more interest right so this bond becomes
a double a bond because it's the the
odds that you are not going to get your
money are not the odds that this guy
default but it's now the odds that this
guy default and Moody's or the standard
of support and poor's have already said
that hey you know these guys are good
for the money they're Double A or
whatever so now your risk is really a
double a risk and not a double B risk or
whatever but anyway this happens you
know this is corporation be and maybe
pension fund to wants to lend the
corporation B I know maybe it's maybe
they lend them two billion dollars and
they get they get I don't know they get
twelve percent maybe corporation B is a
little bit more dangerous but once again
they go to this first insurer and I
don't know maybe they get some of it
they get oh let's just say they get
insurance on B and B is a little bit
riskier so they have to pay 200 basis
points 200 basis points goes from
pension fund to to B now this already
this is a little bit dangerous right
because you can think about what's
happening one as long as this insurer
does not get a downgrade from the credit
ratings from S&P or Moody's or whoever
they can just keep it issuing this
insurance there's no limit for how much
insurance they can issue there's no law
that says you know what if you insure a
billion dollars of debt you have to put
a billion dollars aside so that if that
debt defaults you actually you have that
billion you definitely have that billion
dollars there or if you if you insure
two billion here you don't have to put
that 2 billion aside what you have is a
bunch of people who statistically say oh
you know what's the probability that all
of this debt defaults and you know so I
just have to keep enough capital so that
probabilistically whatever debt defaults
I can pay it but you don't keep enough
capital to pay all of the defaulting
debt so you already see an interest
risk forming what if all of all of these
corporations for whatever reason do
start defaulting simultaneously then all
of a sudden this insurance company has
to pay more out insurance than it might
even have and so you have to wonder
whether it even deserves this double A
rating because it actually is taking on
a lot of risk but in the short term
while these companies are you know
everyone is doing well and the economy's
doing well it's a great business for
these guys these guys are just
collecting premiums essentially on the
insurance without having to pay out
anything now let's add another twist on
it
you know these pension funds p1 and p2
it was reasonable for them to get
insurance because you know they were
giving out these loans and then they got
the insurance so they were essentially
hedging the default risk right by buying
these credit default swaps which was
essentially just an insurance policy
from each of from this insurer one but
you could have another party and you
know this this is no less legitimate
really but you could call them Anna
let's call it hedge fund one hedge fund
one and they've done a lot of work and
frankly they often are much more
sophisticated than the pension funds in
fact they almost always are and they say
you know what company B looks really
really really really shady I think 200
basis points for the chance that Company
B default is frankly cheap because I
think there's a huge probability that
Company B default so what I'm going to
do I'm not going to lend Company B money
because I'm anything I think that there
may be about to go out of business but
what I can do is I can buy a credit
default swap on companies B on company
B's debt which is essentially I'm
getting insurance that they fail without
actually lending the money so let's say
I do that from insurer to so I can go
and I'll pay insurer to 200 basis points
a year or 2 percent on however on the
the notional value of the insurance on
getting so let's say it's 200 basis
points and let's say that's insurance on
you know I'm making a big bet so they're
going to give me insurance insurance on
B for I don't know 10 billion dollars
and something interesting is going on
here already B might not have even
borrowed ten billion dollars right so
all of a sudden you have this hedge fund
that is getting insurance on more debt
than B has even borrowed money on right
and that's it's essentially you just
kind of have this side bet between these
two parties this party says you know
what I think it's a good deal I get 200
basis points on the ten billion every
year as long as B doesn't default and
this guy says I think B is going to
default so I think that's a good deal on
that insurance and just so you
understand the math so the notional
value is ten billion dollars so what's
two percent of ten billion
so you see two percent two percent on a
billion is twenty million so it's two
hundred million dollars right two
hundred B if I did my math correct so
they'll pay two hundred million dollars
a year to this insurer
so the two hundred basis points on ten
billion is equal to two hundred million
these numbers maybe are a little bit on
the big side but you know who knows
actually some hedge funds this could be
a huge hedge fund this could be you know
a ten billion dollar hedge fund or even
worse they might have maybe it's a
billion-dollar hedge fund but they've
taken or maybe it's just maybe it's a
twenty million dollar hedge fund but
they've taken a 180 million dollar loan
to essentially you know they to buy this
insurance because they think that B's
collapse is imminent so they're willing
to take that bet right now you know it
might be a good bet if B collapses
tomorrow right what's going to happen
they only dished out maybe 200 million
for maybe that first year although you
normally pay it on a quarterly basis so
they'll pay 50 million every three
months let's say they pay the first
payment 50 million right and then over
the next three months B just goes
bankrupt and people realize that you
know that debt was worth nothing then
these guys get ten billion dollars right
but something else is interesting here I
- they probably did insurance - a lot of
other people - maybe on B's debt right
or maybe they also insured maybe they
also insured A's debt so maybe they gave
some insurance on A's debt as well right
so what happens let's say B all of a
sudden be all of a sudden defaults right
so a couple of things happen
I one is going to op2 let's see I don't
know how much they two billion dollars
right I to the second insurer is going
to owe this hedge fund ten billion
dollars now let's just assume just I too
is good for the money they have ten
billion dollars they pay to this hedge
fund this hedge funds great they get you
know great bonuses for the year and they
go buy yachts etc but this insurer right
here they paid the money they were good
for it but something interesting might
happen all of a sudden Moody's finally
wakes up these ratings agencies and says
oh my god well there's a couple things
that might make them say oh my god
first of all they might say oh look you
had to pay out ten billion dollars and I
doubt that that was the only person you
have to pay maybe they've to pay out a
lot of money now I to insurance company
to you are undercapitalized I am now
going to downgrade your rating so you
were double-a but since you had to give
out all of this capital Moody's is now
going to downgrade you to I don't know
B+ I'm just making these ratings up but
that's that's the sound of how these
ratings happen right a is better be is
worse the mores you have the better it
is but all of a sudden when you when
this guy is b-plus that and this guy
insured let's say some some other
corporations debt for this pension fund
now all of a sudden this insurance that
this pension fund had is no longer worth
is no longer double-a insurance it's now
B plus insurance and maybe this pension
fund by its charter can't hold something
that has a B plus credit rating so
they're going to have to unwind the
transaction or maybe they'll have to
unload the debt that was insured right
so one just buy Company B defaulting
maybe this guy was holding some of
companies A's dead and it was insured by
insurance company one now they're gonna
have to unload that debt so just just
one default creates this chain reaction
right this one default happens this guy
has to pay this guy money then this guy
gets undercapitalized since they have to
pay out money then moody says oh my god
your undercapitalized we're going to
reduce your ratings maybe this guy was
insurance insurer
some of ADEs debt but now since he was
insuring some of A's debt all of a
sudden that that that insurance is worth
less because it has a lower rating and
now a is a zet less people will want to
hold it because there are less people to
insure it I know that's very confusing
but this is really the point that Warren
Buffett was saying when when when he
said that the the credit default swap
marketer and in general the derivative
market are financial weapons of mass
destruction because you have so many
people who didn't have to set aside a
capital right this guy could insure 10
billion dollars worth of debt without
having to set aside 10 billion dollars
and you have so many people making all
of these side bets but they're all
making two core assumptions one that
these rating agencies ratings are valid
and two that the other person is good
for the money but if all of a sudden you
have one failure someplace in the system
you can have this cascade where one
there's just a lot of downgrades and
then a lot of the people end up not
being good for the money